- All right, gentlemen.
Each of your weapons
will now be tested.
And up first, the kill test.
Doug.
The Spanish navaja, an iconic
folding weapon from history.
It's even said to influence
the American Bowie knife.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
we'll take your Spanish
navaja then deal killing
blows on this deer carcass.
Matthew, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
OK, Matthew.
Nice and solid work right here.
But I'm still recovering
from an injury.
So please welcome
Anthony Palmer.
Anthony is one of the chief
instructors of Marcaida Kali.
Today he will have the
pleasure of wielding
your Spanish navaja.
My biggest concern
going into testing
is the sharpness of my blade.
[music playing]
Your blade is beautiful.
And it's also solid in its feel.
It lacerates easily.
You can see it chopped
right through the spine.
Now, one of the pieces here
came flying out during the test.
But in terms of the sharpness
and the wieldability
of your blade, it will kill.
- Oh, yeah.
- OK, Wade.
It's your turn.
You ready?
- You bet.
Wade, I can hear the
mechanism working in there.
[music playing]
The thud of that deer
carcass hitting the floor
is absolutely the
sound of $10,000.
I feel like I'm ahead.
That's where I want to be.
I want to win it.
All right, Wade,
your blade is sharp.
Thank you.
The one issue is
it's kind of rickety
here, even while it
was being wielded.
But despite being rickety,
it's deadly and it will kill.
Thank you.
DOUG: Next up is
the strength test.
Ben.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge
as well as the
overall construction,
I'm going to smash
into this bamboo
with your Spanish navajas.
Matthew, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
I'm looking at Wade
like he is one up on me.
I have to outperform
him on the strength test
if I'm going to win
this competition.
[music playing]
Well, Matthew, this thing's
one hell of a chopper.
It held together beautifully.
There was slight glinting that
happened up here near the tip,
but it's pretty darn sharp.
Very well done.
Thank you.
Wade, you're up next.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
[laughing]
I'm ahead, he's ahead,
I'm ahead, he's ahead.
We've been this
way the whole time.
It's a battle.
I want to win it.
[music playing]
[bleep]
(WHISPERING) No, it's broken.
Wade, we have a problem.
On about the third
strike, things started
to get kind of loose
and that torquing
and the stress made
your scales pop off.
The only thing holding the
cutting end to the handle end
are these thin brass sheets.
And I don't have confidence
in their strength.
This blade has lost its
structural integrity.
It's no longer safe to test.
Wade, due to the catastrophic
failure of the structural
integrity of your
weapon, we cannot
continue testing that blade.
So I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
I thought I could beat down a
door with that thing, but, you
know, apparently you can't.
I should have put more
weight in the liner just
to make the whole handle
section much more strong.